CARTER MORGAN: Hi.
You guys excited at all?
[CHEERS]
Very cool.
Today, we're going to be
talking about Kubernetes
and best practices
for orchestrating
the cloud with it.
We'll have some live demos of
using industry standard tools
like Docker and Kubernetes.
You'll see us break down an
app into maybe micro services,
package that up in a
container, distribute it,
and then we'll use
Kubernetes to manage that.
I'm Carter Morgan, developer
programs engineer at Google.
And I was going to give
this talk with someone else.
He couldn't make it.
So I'll be driving all the
live demos and whatnot.
Now, before we get into it,
I want to tell you my story.
When I started at
Google six months ago,
I had never worked
on the cloud before.
I had programmed emulators
and compilers at Microsoft.
I had done thread
databases at the Air Force.
But I'd never
worked at the cloud.
So when I started trying to
ramp up, it was overwhelming.
There were so many tools,
so many different processes.
I didn't know where to
begin, where to start.
Luckily, one day I
ended up on a bus
next to this guy
that was literally
writing the book on Kubernetes.
I told him my problem.
I said, I'm having a lot
of trouble ramping up.
And he gave me two
words of advice.
He said, use Kubernetes.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, you want me
to learn another tool
on top of everything
else I'm juggling?
And he said, yeah.
And so he showed me Kubernetes
over the next two-hour bus
ride.
And it turned out he was right.
Kubernetes offered
abstractions that made sense.
It made the cloud
more approachable.
Instead of focusing
on the machines,
I was able to focus on what
I knew, my application.
And so we decided
to make a course.
Over the next four months,
I got to work with and learn
best practices for
approaching the three
major hurdles to writing
scalable applications online.
And so by the end
of this talk, you
will have seen this in
practice with live demos.
So the first hurdle is
the application itself.
I'm not sure why
the image the split.
Oh, it's not, OK.
So you see on screen,
I have a picture
of a monolith application
and a microservices.
We're going to be
demoing these today.
And they're
functionally equivalent.
They do the exact same thing.
We just took a different
design approach.
So how this app works is you can
hit and endpoint and get back
a Hello response.
It's a very, very
polite application.
If we hit a secure
endpoint, we're
not going to be
able to get access
unless we have the right token.
Both of these do the same thing.
But there are pros and cons
to the different approaches
we took.
With microservices,
some of the benefits
are that we can have
independent deployment.
So my off service
or my hello service
can be compiled and
shipped out separately
without recompiling
anything else.
They don't touch.
I can use different
languages for that.
So I could use Go
for hello and off.
And I could use Node.js for
the front end if I wanted.
And then also, these
services are smaller,
which means it's easier
to maintain and manage.
One person or a small team
can own any of these services
from end to end, from
building the code
to running it in production.
Now, these advances in
how we design applications
were made possible by advances
in application isolation
technologies like
containers and VMs.
What containers and VMs
were developed to solve
were the problem of it
works on my machine.
We wanted something that was
reproducible and reliable
and that would
work on any system.
We wanted to be able to
build it once and ship
an application to different
operating environments.
So on screen, you see a
picture of a boat or ship.
And on top of that
are containers.
In this example, the
operating systems is our boat.
And the containers work
within that to give isolation
to our application.
The containers are
application containers.
And what happens is inside of
there, we have an application.
All of its dependencies in its
environment are bundled up.
They don't touch any
other running application
on our system.
So we could, say, bind
port 80 on both of these
without any kind of conflict.
It's very convenient.
Or we could have
two applications
that use the same library,
but different versions,
without any conflict.
So we're isolating
our application
away from the
operating environment
and away from any other running
application on our system.
Containers are also very
lightweight because they're
a construct within
our operating system.
So this means that
starting a new application
with the containers is simple
as loading or unloading
a container onto a boat.
If we were using
virtual machines,
to get the same
kind of isolation,
we would have to
rebuild the boat.
And that's effective,
but maybe not efficient.
So as a best
practice, we're going
to use containers to package
and distribute our applications.
And I'm actually going
to demo this now.
So I'll be demoing Docker, which
is a container image format.
It's very popular.
The same principles would
work if we were using
Rocket, another image format.
The command lines
would be different.
And so the very first
thing I want to do
is build my application.
I'm using Go version 1.6.
There's no magic here.
I'm going to build the
monolithic version first.
And then later, we'll use
the microservices one.
It's just easier
to show everything
when it's bundled up as one.
Normally, if you
build Go, it's not
this complicated to write out.
But I want to build
a static binary.
And so that is a
little more involved.
Oops.
OK, now, once this
is built, we're
going to have a binary
that we can test out.
And I'll be able to show
you the functionality
of this application.
Both the monolith
and the microservices
do the same thing.
We've just broken
the microservices up
into smaller components.
So now that I have a
binary, I can run it.
I'm going to find some ports.
I'm actually going to run
that in the background.
And now I can do things
like curl to the endpoint.
And I get back a greeter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CARTER MORGAN: Ah, thank you.
You guys are paying attention.
I like it.
So I got back a greeter.
If I were to hit up
the secure route,
I'm going to be denied access.
So what we're going to
have to do is log in.
I'm going to use the super
secret password-- "password."
And I have a token now.
So I'm going to pass
that token as a header.
And this will give us access
to this secure endpoint.
Now, that's the
only time I'm going
through all of these steps
the rest of the demo.
For everything
else, I'm just going
to hit the regular endpoint.
It's a lot of steps.
But so now we have a binary.
It works.
We've tested it out.
We want to be able
to run this binary
on any machine on any system.
And that's where
Docker comes in.
So I have a Dockerfile.
And what this is it's
steps to recreate an image.
We're going to take
all of the dependencies
to run an application.
And we're going to bundle
this up into one image.
So the very first line is
saying, what is our base image,
or what is our base
operating system?
Now, as a best practice,
we want to use something
that's very, very small.
We don't want to bundle
unnecessary things
into our application.
So Alpine Three One is
five megabytes in size.
But it still gives
us the functionality
where we could SSH
into a container
and ping and make sure
that our internet is
working, basic debugging
we'd need in production.
Further down, you see that I'm
taking the binary I just built.
And I'm going to store it in the
container at user bin monolith.
And then when I
started the container,
I'm going to run the monolith.
So I can start this
container and run it pretty
much like an application.
So I'm actually
going to do that now.
I'm going to build the image.
I'm going to give it
a name-- Monolith.
And I'm going to give
it a version-- 1.0.0.
And what we see
here is we're taking
the content of that directory,
and we're setting it
up to a build [INAUDIBLE].
And it's going to recreate
an image from this.
And the image should be 13 megs.
Because we have eight
megabytes for avocation
and then five for Alpine.
Now, one reason
this was so small
is because we didn't use Docker
to build our application.
We used Docker as an environment
to package and distribute.
We built our
application outside.
And that lets us do things like
use a continuous integration
system or manually build an
application like I just did.
So we keep our Docker
images really small.
So now, I'm going to push
my image on to the cloud,
or into the cloud.
This is going to
go up to Docker Hub
because I didn't specify
a different registry.
We could use differ ones
like quay.io or gcr.io.
And that's just prefixing it.
Docker Hub is the default one.
So that's just what I used.
Now, what this lets
me do is if I get rid
of the image on my
local machine-- oops--
so now I don't have that
image of my local machine.
It doesn't exist.
If I were to run
and say Docker, I
want to use that image-- let
me fix a typo right quick--
it couldn't find
the image locally.
So it went and pulled this down.
So now I can do things
like find the image ID.
I can inspect it to
get an IP address.
And now I can hit
this endpoint just
like the application I
had locally on my machine.
So that's pretty cool.
We now have an image that we
can ship to almost any operating
environment and
it's going to run.
If Docker is installed,
this is going to work.
So at this point, I
thought I knew everything
I needed to know to write
scalable applications
for the cloud.
I knew how to break it down
into smaller pieces that
were easier to maintain or
easier to ship and distribute.
I knew how to package
those into a container.
And I knew how to ship those.
But it turns out that packaging
and distributing applications
is a small part of it.
We have to worry about is your
container running in the wild?
Is it online?
Once it's up there,
how do you discover it?
How do you access it?
How do you connect
network to it?
Security-- how do
you manage passwords
and sensitive information?
There's a lot of complexity that
comes with managing containers.
And so as a best practice, we
want to automate and monitor
everything we can.
Because we don't
want to get woken up
in the middle of the night
responding to a pager
to jump on a terminal
or command line just
to restart a container.
We want to use a framework
or something that
can handle this complexity for
us and monitor and automate
as much as we possibly can.
Now ideally, this
framework isn't
going to lock us in into
any one way of doing things.
We don't want to be locked into
a container format, a cloud
provider, or again, any
specific set of tools.
We want a framework that's
going to be flexible and let
us tell our own story.
Because as our
application evolves,
the tool that we're going
to use is going to evolve.
And this leads me to Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is an open source
container automation framework.
It's written in Go.
And it's hosted
entirely on GitHub.
So you can go and check it out
yourself, even commit to it.
It's an open API.
So CoreOS uses it with AWS, GCP.
We use it.
You'll see me using Google
container NGINX, which
is a hosted version.
Microsoft uses it too.
So you're not locked in
any one cloud provider.
It's pluggable.
So you can write like your own
scheduler or your own tooling
with it.
And it's based on years
of Google's experiences
with running
containers internally.
So it's something that will let
you scale up from a small app
like I'm demoing today
to production needs.
You see that there's a lot
of enthusiasm with Kubernetes
as well too.
On screen, you see a snapshot
of the commits to GitHub.
And for the version 1.2 release,
there was over 5,000 commits.
So Kubernetes is
really fastly growing.
Now, during this demo,
I don't have time
to show you all of the
features in Kubernetes.
Version 1.2 was designed
to make it easy to scale
and easy to deploy.
1.3 is adding a lot
of very cool features.
Maybe after, come find me.
We can talk about more of them.
Today, I'm going to show you the
basics to get started and clear
the remaining hurdles.
And so you can see that there's
over 1,000 external projects
that are based on Kubernetes.
It's one of the top
projects on GitHub.
And there's companies that
are using it with 100 nodes
or 100 machines up to 1,000.
So today, I'm showing a
very small application.
But Kubernetes is
a framework that
will let you grow from
little to much bigger.
And the best way to see
the power of Kubernetes
is to demo it.
So what I'm going
to show off here
is using Kubernetes to
run that same image.
So before we use Docker
to run a monolith,
now we're going
to use Kubernetes.
So I could say kubectl, which
is the Kubernetes command line
tool.
Let's say run.
Now, what happens here
is Kubernetes created
what's called a deployment.
I'm going to explain each and
every one of these concepts
after this.
But what this does is behind
the scenes it creates some pods.
And pods, you can think of
them as our applications.
So I have an instance
of our application
running in the background.
If we look further, I'm going
to actually describe it.
We can see all the
steps that I've
got running in the background.
I work at Google, but spelling
is very difficult for me.
OK, sorry.
So I actually want
to describe this pod.
Because we can see
the Docker commands
I've got running in
the background for us
by Kubernetes.
So I'm going to make this
smaller for a second.
Can you guys still see that?
All right.
So we'll see that after our
container was scheduled,
we pulled the image.
Just like I pulled
it manually before,
Kubernetes pulled that for us.
And then it actually created
a container with that image
and started it.
So Kubernetes handled
all of the Docker for us.
Now, I want to be able
to access this pod.
And pods get internal IP.
So I could use port
forwarding or I could
use some kind of init scripts.
But there's other ways to do it.
Kubectl gives you
an expose command.
I'm going to open up port 80.
And I'm going to make
the type load balancer.
This takes a second to start up.
What this did is
it created what's
called a service, a
persistent endpoint for us
to access our pods with.
If I look at this
service, right now
it doesn't have an
external IP address.
It's creating one.
So let's actually
check that out.
You can see that
we automatically
picked up an endpoint.
It saw our pod.
If I were to scale up my
application, or make three,
we can see that we picked
up these endpoints.
Our service pick those
up automatically.
So it's feeding traffic
to our application
without us having to
manually configure that.
If I were to look behind the
scenes a little bit further,
I can see that I
have three versions
of our application running too.
So let's send traffic to them.
I now have an external IP
address that I can hit.
And I get our
familiar message back.
So what was happening
behind the scenes there?
Everything starts
with an application.
And in Kubernetes, the
application is the pod.
You can think of it as one or
more containers housed together
that know how to play
well with each other.
They're going to be
scheduled together.
They can communicate
with each other.
They share a namespace.
So if we have data files
that we want to access,
every container in
this pod can access it.
We also have one
IP address per pod,
which is pretty nice
because I can have
two versions of my application
running, and they can,
again, both bind port
80 with no conflict.
Now, every object
in Kubernetes gets
this is arbitrary
key value data.
And this is how we do grouping.
This is how our service
was able to pick up
the pods behind the scenes.
So on screen, you see that
I have two applications.
And they both have labels.
They have a version,
and they have a track.
If I were to select
the v1 version,
I would select
every application.
So before my service
was selecting everything
that was at equals monolith.
If I were just to
select track=stable,
I'd only get one of those.
Now, we talked about
services a little bit before.
Services are persistent
endpoints for IP addresses.
They can be internal
or external.
So if we have back
ends that we want
to be able to communicate
with each other,
we would use a service for that.
But if we wanted to access
these outside of our cluster,
we would also use
a service for that.
These are dynamically created.
So our services can
dynamically pick up
pods to send traffic to.
And they can have
different types.
We saw the load balancer one.
And that's just going to round
robin traffic to pods that
are targeted by our service.
Now, to this point, I haven't
really talked about machines.
Does anyone notice that?
So the reason why is Kubernetes
abstracts away the machine
so we can focus on
our application.
Deployments are an
object that manage
our pods or our
applications for us
in order to manage
scheduling them.
So on screen, you'll see that I
have two machines called nodes.
And I have one version
of my application,
one replica that I want running.
Deployments are used
to drive our desired
state or our current state
closer to our desired state.
So if I want one, I've
got one, I'm good.
But if I change that
and I say I want two,
the deployment [INAUDIBLE]
is scheduling a second node.
If a machine were to
go down, Kubernetes
would handle rescheduling
the second one
until our current state
matched our desired state.
That's pretty powerful.
So now I'm going to take
our application that we've
been using, the monolith.
And I'm going to use
Kubernetes to show you
how to the set up deployments
for a microservices version
of the app.
So we're going to have
our external facing front
end that can be accessed
outside of our cluster.
And we'll have two
persistent back end
services-- our off and
hello-- all communicating
with each other.
So the first thing I want to
do is show the configurations
for our front end service.
We're going to be
listed on port 443.
And this is going to
be a secure endpoint.
So we're going to have
to pass sensitive data.
I'm not going to get
into this too much.
I'm just going to
manually create it here.
But Kubernetes gives you a
way to pass sensitive data
without baking it
into your container
or storing it
publicly on GitHub.
And then I'm also going to
say if I hit my default route,
I'm going to forward that
traffic to the hello endpoint.
This is a named endpoint.
And Kubernetes is going
to set this up for us.
So I don't need to know the
IP address as long as I set up
my services.
If I hit the login
endpoint, then I'm
going to pass that to the
authentication handler.
So really quick, I'm going
to create that configuration
data that I need.
And I'm just going to make
that from a file we just saw.
I'm also going to create a file
for our sensitive data as well.
And all of these commands
are in GitHub publicly.
So you can follow along.
And they're also in
the space I think
it's called that
they set up for I/O.
So if you want to see everything
I'm running, check that out.
OK, now that we have
that data, let's
look at some of
our other systems.
So for our off
service, we're going
to create a service named off.
We're going to forward traffic
from port 80 to port 80.
This is an internal service.
We're not saying it's a
load balance or anything.
So we can only access
this internally.
But if you notice,
this is where we
got the name for our endpoint.
If we look at the
deployment, we're
using the askcarter off image.
And we're just taking
traffic on port 80 and 80.
So I'm actually going to
go ahead and create that.
And I'm going to do
something very similar
for the hello service.
Oops.
So if we were to
look at our service
now for the front end, which
is a little more complicated,
we can see that we're
going to take traffic
on port 443, which our
NGINX is looking for,
the internal container.
And we're going to load
balance to any pods that
are picked up by this service.
And if we were to look at
our deployment as well,
you can see that
we're just using--
we're using NGINX for that.
And so this data that we mounted
before, that we created before,
this is going to be
mounted by our container.
Kubernetes is going to
take care of loading
all of our sensitive
data in our configuration
before we even start our pods.
So I'm actually going
to create that now.
So let's look at the
state of the world.
Oops.
If we look at everything
we have going on,
we have our monolith
that we created before
with three replicas.
We have the hello service
with seven replicas.
We have a front end and we
have an off system, one each.
If we were to look at the
services we have created,
we have our monolith.
And our front end is still
loading up its external IP.
And once it does, we'll be
able to send traffic to it.
And it's going to know how to
communicate with its back ends
that were set up.
Kubernetes handled that
for us so we didn't have
to manually hook all that up.
That's pretty cool.
So I'm actually going to
wait for that to come online.
And while I'm waiting,
I'm just going
to change the number of
pods we have right now.
So I'm going to say
my hello service--
I think that seven is too many.
So I'm going to
change that to be six.
Does anyone here use vim?
I need some of you guys
to teach me this after.
[LAUGHTER]
None of that.
So, sorry.
So I'm going to apply that
change to my deployment file.
Thank you.
And now if I look at the number
of pods, it's hard to tell.
Now, if I look at
the deployments,
I can see that I have
six of that application.
So scaling is really easy
with these deployment files.
So let's actually send
some traffic that way.
I have a front end.
This one is secure.
I got that very
familiar message back.
So I'll be honest.
At this point, I thought I knew
everything I needed to know.
I knew how to break
an application down
into smaller bits.
I knew how to package that into
application containers that
could be shipped
and distributed.
And I knew how to use an
automation tool to automate
and monitor everything.
What more was there
for me to learn?
Well, someone asked me,
what about code updates?
What if the intern Bob
is coding blindfolded
again and he ships bad code out?
It happens.
Well, in that case, we
want a deployment story
that's going to let us roll
out updates cautiously,
but roll back
instantly if we need
to if something goes wrong.
Some best practices
in this field
have turned out to be
blue-green deployments
or canary deployment.
And you do that with Kubernetes.
But what I want to show
you is our rolling update.
But as a best practice,
we want to make sure
that we have a way
to deploy cautiously.
So on our deployments,
if you push on an update,
there's an option.
And we could say we
want a rolling update.
And what that'll let
us do is gradually
scale up a new version of our
application, send traffic to it
at the same time as our old
application is getting traffic,
and then gradually
roll down the other one
as we're scaling
up the new version.
And what this lets us do
is if something goes wrong,
we can minimize downtime.
Because we still have our own
version of the application
in production.
So if I ran the command, I could
spin up my new application,
goodbye.
I'd start getting traffic.
So now both are getting
traffic at the same time.
And I gradually start
spinning down the old one
until I have whatever the
desired state of the new one
was-- in this case, three.
So let's check that out.
So this time, what
we're going to do
is we're going to
change some code.
And since we're near
the end of the talk,
instead of saying
hello, let's say
goodbye, which makes
me kind of sad, guys.
We're going to rebuild
our application.
And once that's
built, we're going
to package this into a Docker
container and ship it back out.
From there, we use Kubernetes
to roll out this new change.
And we can see it live.
So we're going to make 2.0.
So far, we've been
using hello 1.0.
I created those images earlier.
Oops.
While that's writing, I'm
going to start a little script.
All this script does is it just
constantly pings the endpoint.
There's no magic here.
I'm grabbing the front
end's external IP address.
And then I'm just going
to constantly curl it.
So right now, I'm
getting hello messages.
Once I push this
change-- so we're
going to push this
change up to the cloud.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to actually modify
our deployment file.
This time, I'm going to
tell the hello service
to use a different
version of-- this time I'm
going to tell the hello pod
container to use version 2.0.
Once I apply that
change, we're going
to start seeing the new
one getting traffic.
So this takes a little bit.
This is a gradual process.
It's not instantaneous.
What we'll start seeing
is goodbye message
getting sent out.
So we're getting
a few right now.
Over the next few
seconds, we're going
to see more and more
until eventually, all
we're getting back is goodbye.
So we just did a live
update of our code.
It's a very small
sample application.
But there was no down time.
Now, if something
happened, and maybe I
didn't want to tell
you guys goodbye,
I could undo that roll out.
And we're seeing the traffic
start to revert back.
So Kubernetes makes it very easy
to push out updates and changes
to code and have that
taken care of for you.
And now we're starting to
see some of our hellos.
And eventually, this is
going to go back to the state
that we had before where
it's all the hello version
of our application.
And that's pretty cool.
So to start wrap up, some
of the best practices
we talked about-- there's
three major hurdles
of getting an
application online.
There's the application.
We want to make sure to
package that in something that
can be shipped everywhere.
So we're going to use
containers as a best practice.
For the infrastructure needed
to manage that complexity,
we want to automate and
monitor whatever we can.
And we want to make
sure that we're not
locked into any set of tooling.
Finally, we want to make sure
that once we're in production,
we deploy cautiously with
care and that we can roll back
when we need to.
So Kubernetes gives
you all of this.
Now, I learned these
things from an expert
over four months
of making a course.
But taking advice
from a guy on a bus
is normally not good
for your career.
So check out the
Scalable Microservices
with Kubernetes course.
Kelsey Hightower, myself,
Adrian Cockcroft are all in it.
It's part of Udacity's
DevOps Nanodegree Program,
which is just starting up.
I've taken some of the classes.
It's pretty cool.
And in fact, it's
probably easier
to just have the trailer
tell you instead of me.
So I'm going to play that now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Containers,
microservices, Kubernetes--
these are a few of the hottest
buzzwords in scalable computing
today.
But what's driving the hype?
In the last decade, user demand
for always-on applications
have grown exponentially.
Users expect their favorite
sites and favorite services
to be up 24/7, no exceptions.
Many developers are focused
on application patterns
such as microservices
to meet this need.
But what about
the infrastructure
needed to support
these always-on apps?
This course from
Google and Udacity
is going to show you step by
step from theory to production
how to meet and exceed
these demands using
tools that are available today.
Learn from industry experts
like Google's Kelsey Hightower
and the former cloud architect
of Netflix, Adrian Cockcroft,
about modern
application design, best
practices for using Docker
to package and distribute
containers, and how to
manage deployments and scale
applications with Kubernetes.
So what are you waiting for?
If you want practical,
hands-on advice
for containerizing your app
and managing it at scale,
sign up today.
[END PLAYBACK]
CARTER MORGAN: So I'm
really proud of that course.
And I don't know if you guys
saw the magical fist bump,
but that's how you feel inside
if you take this course after.
So to wrap up, I
just want to say
Kubernetes is a container
automation framework
system that's flexible.
It's open.
It's very powerful.
And it lets you
tell your own story.
So this was my Kubernetes story.
I definitely want to hear yours.
I'm not going to have
time for questions.
So you can hit me up
on Twitter always.
I do want to hear your story.
Or you can find us at
the sandbox outside.
Thanks for checking
that out, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]